check check one two one two three four
five
wrongly
all right
audio check one two one two
audio check one two yeah i heard it
earlier i don't hear it now
okay i hear myself but check check check
check check
audio check one two one two one two one
two one two one two
check check check check check
check check check so yeah here back here
but i don't hear it out there
check check check
good jeff we'll want to keep going
audio check one two one two one two one
two one two
audio check
wow
audio check check check check one two
one two
check one two three four
five
so
check check check audio check one two
one two one two three one two three one
two three
audio check one two one two one two
three four five
one two one two one two audio check one
two
one two three one two three four five
four five
all good
oh
okay
not getting a jeff check check check one
two audio check one two one two
audio check one two one two three one
two three one two three
audio check one two one two one two
three one two three
audio check one two one two one two one
two three four five
six seven eight audio check one two one
two
one two one two audio check one two
one two three one two three four five
six seven eight audio check one two
one two one two one two one two three
one two
three four five six seven eight one two
three
audio check one two one two
let me know what you want me to continue
on good
i don't think i'm good
okay
huh
yeah i know that's what she was saying
she said even like this
oh
good night
thank
okay
foreign okay
um
oh my god
uh
bye
so
yes
nice
just as well
how many different subjects do you have
oh
how does that look okay so uh
what was mixing me up
i just want to be close to my heart hey
ali
yes i'm gonna ask you to read here
is
hey
um
okay
uh pretty cool
please
[Music]
you're here
545
next
oh
is
oh
it's cool
yes
okay
no i saw
what's
um
uh you know there's more than that
there's three
okay
immune responses all right
uh
yes
okay
oh um
i can't wait to see you though
it's not very pretty
what we don't
one two three four
just like it says
five three two one
one more time five four three two one
two three four
uh
but they are foreign
are you sure
yep it's good one two three
um
um
oh
i'm thinking
games
yes
just like music
uh
i think that would be really good
i
um
okay
two minute warning
burnout
more
thank you very much
let me begin by expressing our sadness
at the passing of
a wonderful man and a dear friend of
mine herman cain
he was a very special person i got to
know him very well
and unfortunately he passed away from
a thing called the china virus and we
send our prayers
to herman's great wife gloria
wonderful family and i have to say
america grieves for all of the 150 000
americans
who had their lives taken
by this horrible invisible enemy
we mourn their loss as a nation
we mourn their loss as people as people
that love one another
and we're working very hard
to not only contain
this horrible event this horrible plague
it's what it is as a plague but also to
come up with therapeutics and vaccines
and we're making a lot of strides
all over the world they're having
tremendous problems resurgence
has taken place in many countries that
people thought were doing well
despite a wide range of approaches to
the pandemic between
countries this resurgence in cases
is occurring throughout
large portions
of our planet in japan china
australia belgium spain france germany
hong kong places where they thought it
was
they've really done great uh it came
back
and in a couple of cases came back very
strongly
the virus was said to be under control
but new cases have
risen very significantly once again
so when you think somebody's doing well
sometimes you have to hold your
decision on that you have to hold your
statement since the beginning of june
daily new cases
have increased by a factor of 14 times
in
israel 35 times
that's 35 times in japan and nearly 30
times in australia just to name a few
these were countries that were doing
incredibly well
leadership was being praised latin
america now leads the world in
confirmed infections and with the
scarcity of testing in latin america the
true numbers you have no idea what they
might be
and i can say scarcity of testing almost
anywhere except for
our country this disease
is highly contagious and presents unique
challenges to
our border states meanwhile states like
california washington state maryland
virginia nevada
illinois oregon and many others they
were thought to be doing well and they
had
a big resurgence and were hit very hard
and governors that were extremely
popular
are not so popular anymore they were
held
up as models to follow and then they got
hit and i'm not even saying it's their
fault
it's probably not their fault it's just
the way it is that's the way it
is highly infectious one of the most
infectious diseases that anybody has
ever seen
not since 1917 over a hundred years ago
has anyone seen anything like
what we're witnessing now but these
states have also seen the virus
substantially
rebound and again no one is immune
no one is immune these facts
illustrate the imposing
determinant and it is a determinant that
a blanket shutdown to achieve a
temporary reduction
in cases is certainly not a viable
long-term strategy for any country
people are starting to understand the
disease now
we certainly have understood a lot
about the disease that we didn't have
any idea we didn't nobody ever saw
anything like this the primary purpose
of a
shutdown was to flatten the curve ensure
sufficient
hospital capacity and develop effective
treatments and therapies to reduce
mortality and we've done that
but it can come rearing back when you
least suspect it
we did the right thing initially we
saved millions of lives
what we did did the right thing
but a permanent shutdown
would no longer be the answer at all
a small shutdown of certain areas but we
don't want to do that
small shutdowns can be very helpful but
not for long periods of time we
understand what we're dealing with now
but it's a very complex situation
and i can only say thank heaven that we
that we are so advanced in what we're
doing in terms of
vaccines and therapies we now know a
great deal about the virus and how to
treat it and
who it targets almost half of the deaths
come from
less than one percent of our population
think of it half of the deaths
really a tremendous number half of the
deaths come from
less than one percent of our population
those living in nursing homes and
assisted living facilities the average
age of those who die
from the illness is 78.
we've announced very strong measures to
protect those who are
most vulnerable the scientific path
forward is to
protect those at highest risk while
allowing those at lower risk to
carefully return to work and to school
with appropriate precautions
i'm once again urging the american
people to protect their
dear family and friends and anybody
who's
elderly especially if somebody's elderly
and they have
heart problems if they have
certain illnesses diabetes is
a very bad one having to do with what
we're discussing
but you want to protect the elderly and
socially distance
wear a mask if you cannot socially
distance
and practice vigorous hygiene everyone
even healthy young people
should be taking extraordinary care to
avoid infecting
those at the highest risk from this
terrible disease
the elderly and those with chronic
health issues have to be protected in
the current hot spots across the sun
belt
the data is showing very encouraging
signs
arizona in particular has crossed an
important threshold
for every person with a virus we're now
seeing an average of less than
one additional person infected and the
numbers are coming down and coming down
very substantially
they're starting to come down in florida
arizona is really leading away i was in
texas yesterday and they're starting to
come down
significantly we believe in texas need
another few days to figure that one out
but it looks like they're coming down
very significantly
earlier today i visited the red cross
headquarters
to discuss plasma therapy which is a
tremendous tremendous thing that they're
looking at
and they have a lot of experience with
it potentially life-saving treatments
that infuse
sick patients with powerful antibodies
donated by those who have recovered
successfully from
this disease more than two million
americans have recovered from the virus
and today
we're asking them to visit
coronavirus.gov
coronavirus.gov and volunteer to donate
plasma we need plasma it's something
that's been very effective
and we need plasma from those that were
infected and successfully recovered as
most people do
most people do plasma is one of the many
promising treatments my administration
is accelerating
we've secured over 90 percent of the
world's supply of
rem deciver which is terrific
an encouraging anti-viral drug that can
effectively block replication of the
virus
we've also approved the use of the
widely available
steroid which has been very successful
dexamethasone
which has shown success even in patients
at more advanced
stages of the disease on july 17th
we announced a 450 million dollar
agreement with
regeneron to build manufacturing
plants and hundreds of thousands of
doses of
its antibody treatment which is
currently in
late stage clinical trials moving along
very rapidly
that's regenerate as a result of such
significant
strides and treatment the mortality rate
in those over the age of
18 is 85 percent lower
than it was just in april so in a very
short period of time
think of that at just 18 85 percent
lower than it was in
april it's a big statement now i want to
provide an
update on our efforts to ensure a strong
economic comeback
including our negotiations on capitol
hill
throughout this crisis my administration
has taken the most aggressive action in
history to
rescue american workers we love our
american workers
and we've set records on job creation
records
two months in a row we enacted a three
trillion dollar
economic relief package the paycheck
protection program alone saved over 50
million
jobs we delivered 300 billion dollars to
direct cash payments to americans
we approved 500 billion dollars for our
hardest hit
industries 500 billion dollars
we allowed struggling homeowners to
reduce or defer their mortgage payments
and we put a nationwide moratorium on
evictions from federally backed
properties
it's a big thing very big thing we also
suspended student loan payments for six
months
and we're looking to do that
additionally and for
additional periods of time as a result
of these extraordinary steps by
the administration we added a record
seven million
jobs in the two months past
alone to ensure this comeback continues
which we think it will we had great
foundation to build on
we were the strongest country in the
world nobody close we were outdoing
everybody from china
if you remember for many years you heard
that in
2019 china would surpass the united
states well it didn't
we gained on them very significantly
we took it to a level that nobody's ever
seen 2019
and we'll be back there very shortly it
won't take very long
based on everything that we're seeing
it's not going to take very long i think
next year is going to be an excellent
year maybe one of our best years
ever from an economic standpoint
we can never ever forget the
people that have been lost and we never
will we'll never forget them
never forget what happened this could
have been stopped in china they should
have stopped it
and they didn't but i'm asking congress
to pass additional legislation to
support americans in need
first we want a temporary extension of
expanded
unemployment benefits this will provide
a critical bridge for
americans who lost their jobs to the
pandemic
through no fault of their own this was
not anybody's fault
from the standpoint of jobs it happened
terrible thing happened could have been
stopped it happened
i want to thank senate republicans for
fighting to
extend unemployment benefits today and
to face a very strong democrat
obstruction which i'm surprised at
because this is great for our country
and it's great for our workers and it
wasn't our workers fault
second we're asking democrats to work
with us to find a solution
that will temporarily stop evictions
we do not want people who have lost
their jobs due to the virus to be
evicted from their homes or apartments
we don't want that to happen third we
need democrats to join us
to pass additional economic relief
payments for american citizens
like the payments sent directly to 160
million americans earlier this year
which was a tremendously successful
program
this money will help millions of
hard-working families get by
my administration is also asking
democrats to work with us to pass
105 billion dollars to help schools
safely reopen
children are not at the lowest
risk if you look at what's going on the
younger the better
amazing the immune system for children
the lower
they are in age the lower the risk in
terms of the age group itself
i tell the story that in new jersey with
thousands
and thousands of people dying sadly
dying
the governor was telling me that only
one
phil murphy only one died under the age
of 18 that's incredible with thousands
of
people that died in the state of new
jersey one made
an impact one died under the age of 18.
children are at the lowest risk of any
age group from
the virus indefinite school closures
will inflict lasting harm to our
nation's children
we must follow the science and get
students safely back to
school while protecting children
teachers staff
and family we have to remember that
there's another side to this keeping
them out of school and
keeping work close is causing death also
economic harm but causing death for
different reasons but death
probably more death if governors do not
want to
open the public schools the money should
go to parents
so they can send their children to the
school of their choice so
we say if a school doesn't want to open
or if a governor doesn't want to open
maybe for political reason or maybe not
but there is some of that going on the
money should go to the parents
so they can send their children to the
school of their choice
if schools stay closed the money should
follow the students so families are in
control of decisions about their
sons and daughters about their children
but to pass a bill democrats must reject
the extreme partisan voices in their
party they have tremendous voices
they're looking at
november 3rd and probably a day later
they'll say let's open up the country
but the democrats have to reject the
extreme partisan voices in their party
so that
we can get our country going even
quicker than it's going right now we
have a lot
opening and we have a lot of
states that you thought were doing
pretty poorly from the standpoint of the
virus and are actually coming back very
strong
this pandemic has underscored the
importance of economic policies
that put american families and workers
first
got elected on the fact that i put
america first
for many many decades in my opinion we
put america last
if you look at the crazy horrible
disgraceful trade deals that we've
watched for many years destroy our
country nafta we terminated it we have
usmca now which is a great deal and our
farmers are doing
really well despite the pandemic
but we put america first america's
families first
and america's workers first but that
means bringing jobs and factories back
to our shores
reducing unnecessary regulations and
creating
new training opportunities for jobs and
for the future we've cut regulations at
a level that no president
has ever cut regulations and we've cut
taxes more than any president
in the history of our country americans
always rise to the challenge and we will
emerge more resilient
more self-reliant more independent and
more prosperous than ever before
so i just want to thank you all and if
you'd like we'll take a few questions
steve please
are you going to launch an effort to try
to delay the act of the election
or was that just a trial balloon this
morning well what i want to
explain to people but it doesn't need
much explanation i mean you look at
article after article new york's mail
vote disaster
uh tens of thousands of mail ballots
have been tossed out in this year's
primaries what will happen in november
it's a mess
this is done by washington post can you
believe the washington post of
wallpapers
fake news but in this case it's not fake
it's true
this is done by the wall street journal
here's another one vote by mail
experiment reveals potential problems
within postal voting system ahead in
the november election
and you see what's happening with so
many different places they're doing even
trial runs or a disaster
and i don't want to see an election
you know so many years i've been
watching elections
and they say the projected winner or the
winner of the election
i don't want to see that take place in a
week
after november 3rd or a month or
frankly with litigation and everything
else that can happen
years years or you never even know
who won the election you're sending out
hundreds of millions
of universal melon
ballots hundreds of millions where are
they going who are they being sent to
it's common sense you don't have to know
anything about politics
and the democrats know this the
democrats know this steve
so i want to see i want an election
and a result much much more than you i
think we're doing very well we have the
same
fake polls but we have real polls we're
doing very well i just left texas
and biden came out against fracking well
that means texas is
going to be one of the most unemployed
states in our country
that means oklahoma north dakota
new mexico going to be a disaster
ohio pennsylvania disaster no fracking
i want to have the result of the
election i don't want to be
waiting around for weeks and months and
literally
potentially if you really did it right
years because you'll never know
these ballots are missing you saw
paterson new jersey you saw many other
instances there's tremendous litigation
on that right now
and that doesn't include absentee
absentee is different absentee you have
to
work and you have to send in for
applications you have to go through a
whole procedure
like for instance i'm an absentee voter
because i can't be in florida
because i'm in washington i'm at the
white house so i'll be an absentee voter
we have
a lot of absentee voters and it works so
we're in favor of
absentee but it's much different than
millions of people in california they're
going to send out tens of
millions of voting forms well where are
they going to go
you read where postmen are in big
trouble now
you read where city councils are in big
trouble now voter fraud
all over the the ballots so
no i want to get i want to be standing
hopefully
hand-held high big victory because
we're doing things with our country that
i think nobody else could have done
our country is despite this pandemic
which is
devastating the rest of the world by the
way devastating
one of the the articles that came out
was
the world's coveted resurgence this is
the wall street journal editorial the
main editorial yesterday in the wall
street journal i don't always agree with
them
but they have the world's covid
resurgence
countries hailed as models to see
and then they go the virus returns
at a level like it's never they haven't
even seen we've been giving praise to
certain countries and the virus has now
come to them like
like the first time but it's a very
interesting and it talks about many
countries where everybody was holding
them up and saying what a great job they
did
well it's just one of those things
didn't work out so well
so we want to have
an election i'd love to see voter id
but this is the opposite of voter id the
democrats love it the republicans hate
it
we all agree that absentee voting
it's good mail-in ballots will lead to
the greatest fraud
you know we talk about russia russia
russia for two and a half years and then
they found nothing and there was nothing
but they talked russia russia russia
they talked china
they took all of these countries they
say they get involved in our elections
this is easy you can forge ballots
this is much easier for foreign
countries go ahead
the way in the election is probably a
non-starter wouldn't you agree with that
i i just feel i don't want to delay
i want to have the election but i also
don't want to have to wait for three
months
and then find out that the ballots are
all missing and the election doesn't
mean
anything that's what's going to happen
steve that's common sense
and everyone knows it smart people know
it
stupid people may not know it and some
people don't want to talk about it
but they know it and no we want to have
an election
where people actually go in and what's
your name my name is so-and-so boom you
signed the book like i've been doing for
years
it's very very unfair to our country
if they do this our country will be a
laughingstock all over the world because
everyone knows it doesn't work
how many ballots is he sending in
california's exist 28 million or some
massive number other states are sending
out millions and millions of ballots
well they've done it they had
experiments they had
news organizations experimenting and
look read the story in the washington
post about mail-in voting it's a
disaster i'm very surprised to see that
story
frankly from them the story is a
disaster
so we're asking for a lot of trouble and
uh
no do i want to see a date change no but
i don't want to see a crooked election
this election will be the most rigged
election in history
if that happens too mr president you
said that you
don't want to see a delay in the
election
but then it looks like the process of
these mail-in ballots is going to
continue to november
well we have many court chases john we
have one that's been filed for a while
now in
western pennsylvania as an example on
male imbalance
we give tremendous examples numbers of
examples of all the fraud
and all of the things that have taken
place with respect to male imbalance
just wondering is the net effect of what
you tweeted this morning and what you're
talking about now
to cast doubt on the results of the
november 3rd well it's had an
interesting
impact i didn't know it was going to be
the impact it had
what people are now looking at is am i
right
but not me are all these stories right
about the fact that these elections will
be
fraudulent they'll be fixed they'll be
rigged
and everyone's looking at it and a lot
of people are saying you know that
probably will happen
please jennifer president um to break
the log jam
in congress and to prevent that
unemployment
insurance from lapsing what do you plan
to put on the table tonight
well it's a great question i can't tell
you though because
that wouldn't be very smart from a
negotiating standpoint but we'll be
putting certain things on the table
we want to get money to people it wasn't
their fault
and we want to get money to people and
it has to be substantial it's not their
fault what happened
the fact is people don't like saying it
they know it's true
it's china's fault okay it's not their
fault it's not the worker who lost his
job it's china's fault
and that's the way it is oan please
mr president yesterday dhs came to an
agreement
with the governor of oregon to remove
federal officers and oregon state
troopers took over
mayor ted miller was noticeably absent
from that agreement are you confident
sir
that the state of oregon will be able to
quell the protests in portland
and if the violence does continue would
you consider redeploying federal troops
so our people have done homeland
security have done a fantastic job they
went to oregon
a little more than a week ago uh the
place was a mess
the city portland was just a disaster
uh you see it and a lot of people
weren't reporting it right they tried to
pretend it was a protest as opposed to
anarchists and agitators you understand
what i'm saying
it's a mess they went there short while
ago
and they saved a federal courthouse that
costs hundreds of millions of dollars
and they put a ring around the
courthouse and they saved it but
the group that's there is basically
meant to save buildings and they were
very strong very powerful
and they didn't come out too often out
of this cocoon that they built in order
to save these very
expensive valuable and psychologically
important buildings right like
courthouses the governor and the mayor
we've been dealing with them and we
think they don't know what they're doing
because this should not have been going
on for 60 days
it's not our job unless in case of
emergency which i consider now to be an
emergency
it's not our job to go in and clean out
the cities that's supposed to be done by
local law enforcement
yesterday the governor worked a deal
where they'll do it
we'll stand by they'll do it and that's
good what was very good but she didn't
report it that way what she reported was
totally different
she said i think trump wants to take
over the country
it's crazy so what happened is
our people are staying there to see
whether or not they can do it today and
tomorrow
and if they don't do it we will send in
the national guard and we'll take care
of it
and we're telling right now these
protesters and many should be arrested
because these are professional agitators
these are professional anarchists these
are people that hate our country
we're telling them right now that we're
coming in very soon the national guard a
lot of people
a lot of very tough people and these are
not people that just have to guard the
courthouse and save it
these are people that are allowed to go
forward and do what they have to do
and i think that makes the governor's
job and the mayor's job a lot easier
so they're working today and probably
tomorrow to clean out
uh this beehive of of terrorists
and if they do it i'm going to be very
happy and then slowly we can start to
leave the city
if they don't do it we'll be sending in
the national guard please
mr trump given given what's happening
with major league baseball
and now today the rutgers football team
is quarantined how can you assure
people that schools will be safely
reopened so can you assure anybody of
anything i do say again
young people are almost immune to this
disease
the younger the better i guess they're
stronger they're stronger they have a
stronger immune system it's an
incredible thing nobody's ever seen this
before
various types of flu will hurt young
people more than
older people but young people are
almost immune if you look at the
percentage it's a tiny percent of one
percent it's a tiny percent
of one percent so
we have to have our schools open we have
to protect
our teachers we have to protect our
elderly but we do have to have our
schools open
yeah please mr president a week ago you
said uh
you're in the process of developing a
strategy that's going to be very
powerful
involving the chronovirus where is that
strategy well i think you're seeing it
and i think you will see it
and one of the things that we've done
that we're getting it hasn't been
utilized fully yet but we're all set to
march when it comes to the vaccine
we have great therapeutics that are
testing very well
and we have great vaccines from
incredible companies johnson and johnson
and
pfizer and merck and all of these great
companies and they're doing very well
and the delivery system is all set
logistically we have a general that
that's all he does is deliver things
whether it's soldiers or
other items and i think you're going to
see something that's going to be
spectacular
the fda has approved things at a rate
that's a tiny fraction
of what it would cause what it would
take during a another administration
let's say we are way ahead on vaccines
way ahead on therapeutics and
when we have it we're all set up with
our platforms
to deliver them very very quickly
the vaccines are doing well the
therapeutics are doing well and we're
all set to deliver them as soon as we
have them
and that's going to be very soon thank
you very much
now